well if I have to redesign the world I
would redesign the human being to some
degree there is a very important defense
mechanism that is fear which is of use
but I think in the human collision it's
become an exaggerated phenomenon and in
many ways gets in the way of humanity's
development and cooperation and if I'd
like to reduce that because i think that
the fear dimension is what's getting in
the way of political growth of social
well-being of greater communication Oh
greater interaction between people in
the world but if you were to ask men a
more serious level in terms of practical
ramifications here and now I would like
to see a greater integration of the
different dimensions of the human
condition I would say that the WEF is
trying to do that precisely in the group
will redesign initiative but i would
even here there's a degree of a certain
amount of siloing and i'd like to see
more interaction between the human
spirit and the scientific and the
practical and commercial and every good
company for be able has some kind of
think tank and which people from those
different disciplines and different
perspectives are able to put their
thoughts and together rather than be
suspicious or in any way wary of the
different dimensions of the human
condition